จะ
เอาไหมโทษ
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
ผู้หญิงเท้าอันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วัน
จันทร์ค่ะวันนี้วันจันทร์วันที่เท่าไหร่
คะวันที่
21 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
มีนาคมปีพตตเท่าไหร่คะปีพตต
2565 ปีคศเท่าไหร่คะปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้
เวลา
8 โมงเช้าหมอเขาฆ่าหมู 8 โมงเช้านะคะไม่
มี X ผู้หญิงวันนี้เรามีนักเรียนกี่คนคะ
วันนี้เรามีนักเรียนทั้งหมด 1  2  3  4  5
6  7  8  9  10  10 คนค่ะมีนักเรียนทั้ง
ป.ป.ช. 10 คน
เย้
ผู้หญิงคู๋ยังง่วงนอน
รอเพราะว่าตอนนี้
08:00 นให้ตอนเช้าพระเอกเนี่ยง่วงนอน
แล้วครูเอ๋กินอาหารเช้าหรือยังคะแต่ 08:00
นยังไม่ได้กินหนูหิวมากมีขิวค่าามีผู้
หญิงราคากินอาหารเช้าหรือยัง
รู้หญิงกินแล้วขอครูหญิงกินแล้ว
นะแล้วนักเรียนล่ะกินอาหารเช้าหรือยัง
ครูเอ๋เอ๋อยากรู้ไหมคะอยากรู้นักเรียนนะ
คะกินอาหารเช้าหรือยังงั้นเดี๋ยวถามก่อน
ไว้กินหรือยังเนาะอะไรค่ะโอเคค่ะนักเรียน
ยกมือได้นะยกมือเออครูเอ๋อยากจะรู้นะคะ
เอะลึกขาม 1 คน 1 คน 1 คน
ถาม 1 คน 1 คน 1 คนดีไหมคะโอเคค่ะคุณ
Black ครูเอ๋อยากรู้คุณแมะกินอาหารเช้า
หรือยังคะอ่ะคุณ Black ก็พยักหน้าค่ะ
ขอบคุณ Bag กินอาหารเช้าเสร็จแล้วนะคะ
แล้วคุณโรเบิร์ตล่ะคะคุณโรเบิร์ตกินอาหาร
เช้าหรือยังคะ
คุณโรเบิร์ตบอกว่ากินแล้ว
กินแล้ว
โอเคแค่สองคนนะคุณระเบิดกินอาหารเช้าแล้ว
คุณธนาชิคุณทาดาชิกินอาหารเช้าหรือยังคะ
คุณทาดาชิทรายหน้าค่ะอ๋อคุณทาดาชิยังไม่
ได้กินอาหารเช้า
เหลือนั้นครูเอ๋
คุณณธาราชิครูเอ๋ยังไม่ได้กินอาหารเช้านะ
คะ
คุณ John แท็กสั้น
คุณ John เท็กซัสกินอาหารเช้าหรือยังคะ
คือคุณ John พยักหน้าค่ะจรพญานาคกินอาหาร
เช้าเสร็จแล้วนะคะกินแล้วโอเคค่ะคุณลิซ่า
ขาบริษัทกินอาหารเช้าหรือยังคะคุณลิซ่า
พยักหน้าค่ะครูเอ๋คุณลิซ่ากินอาหารเช้า
แล้วนะคะทั้งคุณประวีณา
คุณประวีณากินอาหารเช้าหรือยังคะก็คุณ
ประวีณาพยักหน้าค่ะอ๋อคุณปวีณากินอาหาร
เช้าแล้วอิ่มแล้ว
เอามือจับที่นี่อิ่มอิ่ม
แล้วนะคะคุณเท่ห์คุณเทกินอาหารเช้า
หรือยังถ้า
คุณเททะยักหน้าค่ะคุณเทกินอาหารเช้า
แล้วนะคะไม่
คุณเธอยิ้มสบายสวายตายอิ่มอิ่ม
อิ่ม
ใช่มั้ยกินอิ่มอิ่มนะคะถ้าคุณ John
สวีเดนคุณ John สวีเดนกินอาหารเช้าหรือ
ยังคะโอเคคุณ John สวีเดนยิ้มแล้วก็พยัก
หน้าค่ะงดกินอาหารเช้าเสร็จแล้วนะคะอ้าว
ไอ้ทำคันเขาคุณ Cash คุณแคทกินอาหารเช้า
หรือยังคะอ๋ออ๋อคุณแคทก็พยักหน้าค่ะพยัก
หน้ากินอาหารเช้าเสร็จแล้วนะคะไอ้โอนสุด
ท้ายคุณเค้า
คุณเค้าร้านอาหารเช้าหรือยังคะอ๋อคุณเค้า
พยักหน้าค่ะลูกคุณเค้ากินอาหารเช้าเสร็จ
แล้วอ๋อครูหญิงก็กินอาหารเช้าเสร็จแล้ว
ครูเอ๋ยังไม่ได้กินแต่กู ami
ami อาหารเช้าอะไรคะพี่เอ็มมิตอันนี้
อะไรครับผู้หญิงถุงกระดาษ
กระดาษครูเอ็มเปิดก่อนนะคะได้ค่ะครับเปิด
แล้วก็มีมือคู่เอกก็จะเอามือล้วง
ล้วงลงไป
แล้วคุยเคยหยิบ
ไหล
เช้าครูเอ๋
อะไรคะครูเอ๋ขนมปัง
แต่เขาเรียกขวดซองด้วยนะ
ขนมปังคือขนมปังโอเคขนมปังขนมปังครัวซอง
ขนมปังแล้วก็ครัวซองบิสกิตโอเค This  Is
ขนมปังไหม
ใช่นะ Toast ขนมปังอะไรขนมปังสวยเก๋ฉีด
หน่อย
ครุ
รถซองเนี่ยอาหารเช้าครูเอ๋
ดึงออกมานะผู้หญิงค่ะปาก
ฟัน
เอกอ้าปากเอาครัวซองใส่ปากค่ะก็อะไรคะ
เดี๋ยว
ถุงเดียว
อร่อยทุ
แต่ตอนนี้ครูเอ๋กินไม่ได้มีคลาสออมีคะกู
เองเก็บก่อนนะคะคลิ๊กเก็บค่ะคลาสเซ็ท
เอาซองใส่ถุงนะคะใส่ถุงแล้วก็ครับ
หรือบางที่นี่ออมีทิชชู่เช็ดบอลค่ะอือ
อออตอนนี้กำลังพูดห้ามกิน
สายเดี๋ยวคลาสเซ็ท
ครูเอ๋เอ๋กินตัวซองเพศได้ค่ะอ๋อผู้หญิง
ผู้หญิงกินอาหารเช้าแล้วใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะ
กู้หญิงกินอาหารเช้าแล้ววันนี้ครูหญิงกิน
อะไรคะ
วันนี้ครูหญิงกินข้าวต้มกุ้งไอเพราะ
ว่ากินกว่า 2 อาคูโอะโอ๋เอ๋ๆน้ำโอเคมั้ย
โอเคค่ะเป็นแก้วแล้วก็น้ำ
กลืนนา
หนาวเอ๋กินก็เลยต้องดื่มน้ำๆครัว 2 อยู่
ที่นี่
ผู้หญิงกินอะไรนะคะวันนี้รู้หญิงกินข้าว
ต้มกุ้ง 5 ไม่รู้จักนะครูหญิงไม่รู้จัก
ข้าวต้มกุ้งโอเคเดี๋ยวผู้หญิงให้ดู
อ๋อ
ใช่ค่ะ
ใจแล้ว
ขอกูู้หญิงคะ
ข้าวต้มกุ้งอยู่อยู่ในอะไรคะอันเนี้ยอยู่
ในทุบอยู่ในชามที่อยู่ในชามนะคะอาร์มและ
ชามรึเห็นคู๋นะสีเขียวเห็นค่ะอ่าผู้หญิง
อันไหนกุ้ง
นี่ค่ะ
กุ้ง
สีส้มๆกุ้งกุ้งแล้วอันนี้อะไรคะผู้หญิง
อันไหนค่ะอ้ออันนี้กระเทียมเจียวค่ะ
กระเทียมเจียวอันนี้นะคะ
ขิงอ่ะแล้วสีเขียวนี้อะไรคะผักชีค่ะอัดชี
อันนี้คืออะไร
ถ้าข้าวอ้าวแล้วก็มีอะไรคะมิมีน้ำซุปน้ำ
ซุปมีสีเขียวเล็กๆ
เล็กๆนิดต้นหอมหมอร้านข้าวต้มกุ้งมีข้าว
มีน้ำซุปมีกุ้ง
มีกระเทียมเจียวมีขิง
แล้วก็ผักชี
ต้นหอม
ใส่ค่ะผู้หญิงทำข้าวต้มกุ้งใช่ไหมคะใคร
ค่ะครูหญิงเท้าเอาแล้วกินแล้วอร่อยไหม
อร่อยมาก
จริงหรอ
มีผู้หญิงทำครูหญิงกินอร่อย
ผู้หญิงทำคู๋กินอร่อยไหม
ต้องเช็คค่ะรอ
ไม่รู้นะคะแต่แต่กูเอนดูแล้วคิดคิดว่า
อร่อยนั้นว่าอร่อยสระคู
ถ้าอยากรู้ว่า
ผู้หญิง YouTube ใคร
รู้นะเรียนกินอะไร
วันนี้อาหารเช้าของนักเรียนน่ะนักเรียน
กินอะไร
คนบางทีเราพูดมื้อเช้ากินอะไรคะโอเคไหม
โอเคค่ะ
นักเรียนคะ
มื้อเช้านักเรียนกินอะไรคะน้อคุณแคทยุค
มือค่ะกูอะไรคะครูเอ๋เอ๋
กู
เอง
เฮ้ยหญิงคุณแคทยกมือคุณแคทบอกว่ามื้อเช้า
กินอะไรคะคุณแคทบอกว่ามื้อเช้ากินคุณแคท
กินครัวซองค่ะครูเอ๋
หน้ากู
เหมือนครูเอ๋ไอ้หยังกูยังไม่ได้กินเออ
เห็นมีตัวซองคู๋ยางไม่ได้กิน
แต่คุณแคะกินครัวซองเสร็จแล้วใช้ค่ะยิ่ง
แคทกินกี่อันกี่ชิ้นค่ะ 1 ชิ้น 2 ที่โล
คุณชาร์จบอก 2 ชิ้นสองชิ้น
อร่อยไหมคุณแคทออกอร่อยคุณ chat พยักหน้า
พยักนะคะออกคุณคะกินครัวซองโอเคค่ะครูเอ๋
อยากรู้ว่าผู้หญิงคุณไข่ดีใครดีคุณคุณคุณ
ๆๆคุณระเบิดถ้าคุณโรเบิร์ตอยากรู้คุณ
โรเบิร์ทใช่ไหมคะคุณระเบิดมื้อเช้าจะกิน
อะไรคะคุณระเบิดกินแล้วใช่มั้ยกินแล้วกิน
แล้ว
คุณระเบิดกินอะไรคะคุณโรเบิร์ตบอกว่าอ้อ
กินไข่ดาวกับเบคอนอ๋อผู้หญิงเป็นยังไงไข่
ดาวนี่ค่ะ
อาหารเช้าคุณโรเบิร์ต
อะไรคือไข่ดาวคะ
ข่าวนี้นะคะผู้หญิงไหมค่ะได้ไข่ดาวแล้วก็
อันนี้เป็น
เบคอนค่ะอ๋อโอโห้ไข่ดาวผู้หญิงชอบกินไข่
ดาวเบคอนไหมคะผู้หญิงชอบไข่ดาวค่ะ Day
ค่อนสอบ
เอ้อเขตคู๋ชอบเบค่อนไข่ดาวไม่ชอบ
Robert กินไข่ดาวเบคอน
อร่อยไหมคะคุณโรเบิร์ตก็ระเบิดยิ้ม 5 บอก
อร่อย
ไอ้นะคะ
คุยขอบคุณค่ะคุณโรเบิร์ตผู้หญิงมีนัก
เรียนกินอะไรอีกก็คุณแร้คมีค่ะคุณแม้คุณ
mad มื้อเช้ากินอะไรคะ
นี่ค่ะอาหารสาวของคุณแบรด์คุณ Bag กิน
เยอะมากโหกินมากๆคุณ Bag กินอะไรมั่ง
เนี่ยผู้หญิงคุณแบรคกิน
กินอะไรอีก 2 ขอเคลียร์แป๊บนึงนะคะคุณ
Black กิน
คุณแบงค์อาหารนี้คุยมี
อะไรคะครูเอ๋ไข่ดาวค่ะชัยค่ะให้แล้วผู้
หญิงผู้หญิงเดี๋ยวเดี๋ยวๆไข่ดาวนักเรียน
ดู 2 ครั้งละอ่าตรงนี้เรียกว่าอะไรคะ
ไข่ขาวค่ะแล้วตรงนี้นะคะเนี่ยชุดถุย
กะไบท์แดงค่ะไข่แดงนะคะไข่ขำ
คุณแม้กินไข่ดาว 2 ฟองค่ะ 2 ฟองนะคะแล้ว
อันนี้อะไรเอ่ยอันในข้างครูเอ๋ขนมปังปิ้ง
ขนมปังปิ้งคุณ Bad กินขนมปังปิ้งกี่แผ่น
คะผู้หญิง 1  2  3  3 แผ่นค่ะหน้าสุดแม้
กินขนมปังปิ้ง 3 แผ่นละอันนี้อะไรคะอ่ะ
ก็เพราะไส้กรอกค่ะไส้กรอกคุณ Bag กินไส้
กรอกกี่ชิ้นคะคุณแบรดกินไส้กรอก 1  2  3
4  4  4 ชิ้นค่ะแล้วก็มีรี่สีแดงๆ
อะไรเนี่ย
มะเขือเทศ
ย่างๆเนี่ยมะเขือเทศยังคุณ Bad กินมะเขือ
เทศอย่างกี่ชิ้นพระ 1  2  3  4  5 คุณ
แร๊ดกินมะเขือเทศย่าง 5 ชิ้นค่ะแต่ตรงนี้
มีอะไรอันนี้
อันนี้นิดนึงเลยค่ะครูเอ๋เลยขอคุณแม็คเอา
เลยมาทำอะไรคะคุณ Rack เอาเนยทาขนมปัง
ขนมปังนะคะไทยค่ะอุ้ยอาหารของคุณแพทอยู่
ต่อไปอะไรคะเนี่ยเนี้ยอยู่ในจานค่ะอยู่ใน
จานคุณแม็คใช้ช้อนไหมคะไม่ค่ะคุณแบรดใช้
ส้อม
แบตใช้ส้อมนะคะอันนี้อะไรผู้หญิงเดี๋ยวลบ
อันไหน
ลบและอันนี้อันนี้อันนี้อันนี้อันนี้น่ะ
จ๊างงานรักใต้จานมีอะไรคะมีถ้าค่ะอ๋อเป็น
ผ้าใช่ไหมคะเป็นผ้า
ลองจานนะคะคุณแม้กินเยอะคิดว่าคุณแบรด
อิ่มอิ่มค่ะ
ละอองผู้หญิงเอกตรงนี้อีกตื้น
เรือไหมอ่ะก็น่าจะเป็นเกลือ
พริกไทยเนาะอันนี้พัดพริกไทย
ถามอาจารย์นะคะโอเคก็รู้แล้วคุณแม็ก in
อะไรนะคะอ่ะค่ะตัวเองลบก็มีก่อน
เราคนอื่นกินอะไรอีกคะครูหญิงเรามาดูต่อ
ไปเลยไหมคะคุณเอ๋ให้ค่าเพราะเดี๋ยว
อะไรอ่ะอันนี้โอ๊ตมีลไข้กินคุณ John คุณ
คุณ John สวีเดนค่ะยกมือขึ้นจรสวีเดนกิน
อะไรอ่ะกูอีกนี้ที่มีอยู่
เนี่ยไอ้โอ๊ตมีลแล้วก็มีผลไม้มี
Strawberry สตอเบอรี่และสีดำอะไรคะเนี่ย
Blackberry ค่ะล้อแม็กเบอร์รี่
อร่อยไหมคุณจอห์นพี่จอห์นยิ้มพยักหน้าบอก
อร่อยอร่อยหรอคะอร่อยโอเคไม่เคยกินนี้ไม่
รู้อร่อยหรือไม่อร่อยและครูเห็นสตอเบอรี่
โอเค Blackberry โอเคโอ๊ตมิว
ไม่รู้นะคะ
ผู้หญิงกินไหมไม่กินค่ะครูเอ๋แล้วคุณ John
ใช้อะไรตักคะ
ท้อนค่ะไปฮ้อนอ่ะหลักอัดใส่ปาก
คุณ John กินโอ๊ตนิ้วและเวียนคนอื่นล่ะคะ
กินอะไรครับผู้หญิงต่อไปนะคะครูเอ๋โอ๋อัน
นี้อะไรคะครูเอ๋แฟน
หน้าจอแซนด์วิชแซนด์วิชอะไรไม่รู้คนไทยจำ
คนไทยพูดแซนวิชขาดไอ้แซนวิชคะผู้หญิงก็
คุณ John เช็คซ่าส์ค่ะคุณจอยกินแซนวิชอัน
นี้ wager ตาเลี่ยนแซนด์วิชหรือเปล่า
เนี่ยเนาะมีขนมนี่ใครมีใครคือผู้หญิงอ้า
ไหนคะครูเอ๋
hz ให้
ไข่อยู่ตรงไหนอ่ะใส่ค่ะ
นี่ไข่ต้มค่ะมีมะเขือเทศ
สีแดงๆมีผักสีเขียวเขียวค่ะแล้วก็ขนมปัง
ปิ้ง
สายการขนมปังเป็นสี่เหลี่ยมทำไม
ถ้าเป็นสามเหลี่ยมครับผู้หญิง 1 เหลี่ยม
สองเหลี่ยมสามเหลี่ยม
ธรรมดาไม่เห็นเป็นสี่เหลี่ยมแบบนี้หนึ่ง
สอง
สามสี่
เหลี่ยม
ทำไมเป็นสามเหลี่ยมนะคะจากสี่เปลี่ยนเป็น
3 มีมีดค่ะครูเอ๋ที่ไหนแล้วก็คันค่ะอ๋อ
เอกชีเมตรให้เกินนักเรียนไม่เห็นมีหน้า
เอามีดผู้หญิงชี้แล้วนี่เราใช้มีดหั่นนะ
คะค่ะหนู
ใหญ่เลยนะ
อิ่มเหมือนกันอิ่มหน้าอิ่มใจหน้าเขานัก
เรียนคนอื่นกินอะไรอีกคะคุย
คุณลิซ่าค่ะค่ะอันนี้ของคุณลิซ่า
ถ้าคุณลิซ่ากินอะไรคะคุณลิซ่ากินไข่คนค่ะ
ไข่คนออกค่ะออกไข่คนนะคะ
ไข่ก็คือมีไก่ก็ตั้ง
ไข่ได้ไข่
ไข่เราแล้วก็มีมีกระทะใช่ไหม
มีกระทะ
กระทะนะคะอะมีถ้วย
มีไข่ที่นี่นะก็มี
อะไรไม่รู้ตี 4 ตีไข่
แล้วก็เอาที่มีน้ำมันมีไฟ
ไข่ใส่กระทะแล้วก็คนๆ
โอเคเสร็จแล้วเสร็จแล้วหรือ
มีอร่อยอร่อยค่ะคุณลิซ่ากินนิดหน่อยนะคะ
นี่ไปคุยซ่าเป็นผู้หญิงผู้หญิงกินนิด
หน่อยโอเคขอบคุณค่ะคุณลิซ่าต่อไปค่ะ
ไป
โอ้ว
อะไรอ่ะคุณโยเกิร์ต On โยเกิร์ตแล้วก็มี
อะไรนะแมกม่ารี่บลูเบอร์รี่อะไรอีกล่ะ
อะ Raspberry ค่ะ Raspberry อันนี้ใคร
ชี้นคุณประวีณากินคุณประวัยนากินโยเกิร์ต
แล้วก็ผลไม้
จ่ายเป็นอาหารเช้าอิ่มไหมอ่ะนิดหน่อยผู้
หญิงกินหน่อย
ๆอ๋อตอนเช้าก็ต้องกินนิดหน่อยอิ่มนะคะค่ะ
ต่อไปไอ้ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงอ่ะมีนักเรียนให้
ดูอะไรอีก
หมดแล้วค่ะหมดแล้วหรอคะโอ้วที่เหลือนัก
เรียนไม่กินอะไรใช่ไหมมีคน
ชี้คนไทยราชิกินอะไรคะคุณทาชิไม่ยังไม่
ได้กินอาหารเช้าก็ไม่ได้กินเอาครัว 2 ไหม
ครูเองเฮ้ย
คุณถ้าได้อินทระที่บอกไม่เอาตอนเช้าคุณ
ธาราชิดไม่กินไม่กินได้สักทีไม่กินโอ้โอ้
คุณทาชิก็เลยตัวนะคะซึ่ง
คุณชาดาชิดื่มกาแฟค่ะครูเอ๋อิ่ม
นี้นะคะกาแฟ
นี่ค่ะคุณทาดาชิดื่มกาแฟดำกาแฟดำ 5
ผู้หญิงดื่มกาแฟไหมคะไม่ดื่มค่ะกาแฟดำ
เนื้อคู่เอกก็ไม่ดื่มกาแฟราคาอันนี้นัก
เรียนดื่มกาแฟไหม
โอ๊ต
ทุกคนดื่มกาแฟ
อ่อนนักเรียนเนี่ยกินแซนวิชกินขนมปังแล้ว
ก็ก็ดื่มกาแฟด้วยอ่า
โปรเอหิวมากๆ
ครูเอ๋จะกินครัวซองนะคลาสเซทพรุ่งนี้จะ
กินตัวซองแล้วลืมอะไรครูเอ๋ไม่เพียงดื่ม
กาแฟเดิมน้ำเปล่าหมูเล่นรอบน้ำเปล่านะคะ
ชอบดื่มน้ำเปล่า
on  8 นักเรียนคนอื่นไม่บอกใช่ไหมกิน
อะไร
มีไหมหมดแล้วราะถ้ามีมีกูเอ๋อันนี้คุณเตะ
กูอีกว่ากูเอ๋อยากจะรู้คุณเปกินอะไร
คุณ Jae  Hee กินซีเรียลค่ะคุณไปทำไม
ไม่กินกิมจิ
ตอนเช้าโอเคโอเคตอนเช้าไม่กินกิมจิกิน
ซีเรียล
ง้อคนไทยก็พูด Serial เนาะใส่ค่ะผู้หญิง
กินไหมไม่กิน
เอกก็มาให้กินนะดีใจค่ะ
อันนี้ค่ะนิดของใครอ่ะคุณเคล้าให้คุณเขา
ยังไม่ได้กินน้องยังยังคุณเขายังไม่ได้
กินให้คุณเขากินแล้ว
กินข้าวกินแล้วใช่ไหมคะนานๆของใครเอานัก
เรียนไม่บอกมา
แต่ไม่เป็นไรนักเรียนไม่บอกไม่เป็นไรคุย
อิ๋งอันนี้เป็นอะไรอ่ะนี่เป็นขนมปังทาเนย
และและที่อยู่ข้างบนเลยขนมปังเนยข้างบน
สุดอะไรคะมีดค่ะนี่ธานีของใครไม่รู้นัก
เรียนส่งรูปให้ครูดูชายลืมของใคร
นักเรียนเนี่ยกินอาหารเช้าแล้วแล้วก็บอก
ว่ากินอะไรเป็นอาหาร
เมื่อเช้าถ้าครูเอ๋เอ๋ยังไม่ได้กินครูเอ๋
หิวกูเองไปกินก่อนได้ไหมคะได้ค่ะเดี๋ยว
Class เสร็จแล้วครูเอ๋จะไปกินครัวซอง
ครัวซองรอนานแล้วก็ได้ดีดกาแฟ
น้ำเปล่าน้ำเปล่าขวดสอบของเขว
จอ
ร้องหิวหิว
แล้ววันนี้ก็หมดเวลาเนาะนักเรียนที่ไม่
ได้มา Class ดูวีดีโอก็บอกได้กินอะไรเป็น
อาหารเช้า
ให้นะคะแล้วก็นักเรียนกินอาหารเช้าไหมคุณ
ธนาชิไม่กินใช่มั้ยฮะไม่กินใช้ค่ะมีใคร
เราไปก่อนเนาะ
ไม่สวัสดีม.ค